so you're not going to believe what the
q shaman's lawyer said in an interview
or you probably will believe what he
said albert watkins the lawyer for the q
shaman said a lot of these defendants
and i'm going to use this colloquial
term perhaps disrespectfully but they're
all
short bus people these are people with
brain damage they're on the
spectrum now watkins is an incredibly
infamous attorney in his own right
the first line of his bio says that he
is quite frankly beyond description now
i don't know if that's true but one
description you might not use his good
lawyer because just because you're on
the spectrum doesn't mean you can't tell
the difference between right and wrong
so that's not a defense for his client
or anyone else
and watkins went on to say they're part
of our country they aren't bad people
they don't have a prior criminal history
they were subjected to four plus years
of propaganda the likes of which the
world has not seen since
hitler interesting move to go after
clemency while being about as offensive
as possible now that probably won't help
in terms of establishing guilt
it might help in terms of sentencing to
try and get less sentencing for the
crimes they will be convicted of but you
know i guess you defend the clients that
you have not the clients that you want
so we will definitely see all of them
in court